ce matin dans ce sens qu'a dit charles
andré mancey bonjour monsieur le maire
de ducos bonjour on a les deux mains
dojo j'en ai vraiment c'est vous avait
réaffirmé récemment sur rci après
l'avoir dit sur france antilles que vous
vous retirez de la municipale en 2020
pourquoi personne n'y croit vraiment à
ducos et honnêtement qui sont pas envie
ville est passée niant le bagage à la
vie à sept moment où ni monica travail
ni moins que l'effet bpa
il est rentré en 2001 bondi du kwassa
l'avant mais le gala dès à présent une
taupe profitation topco tient notre
esprit et ça arrange tout ça qui fait
payer à crier à oiseaux qui m'éloigne
léger kimono cas décrit exactement le
cas prédit ça tout ça tient à la nature
qui est lui qui administratifs liés et
mes collègues se tenir prêt à jouer il
t'a coûté moins donc on peut pas faire
plus confiance en ben ouais je me rabats
maintenance o&m en paca respectives on
encore on ne balaie travail oui et comme
un noir d'un situation et où nous
rappeler de chômage des jeunes s et
cetera alors comme moi même alors qu'il
me bat g data money et de compte estimé
geoff on le prend comme j'ai dit qu'aux
sahpresa qui pète un bébé communio
d'accord jalons du mans c'est le cas pas
les deux coaches et 2004 hays est ce
qu'on ne peut jamais dire ça puisque
brusquement l'ethnie l'action 2015
décembre 2015
l'assemblée de martinique et beyrouth
samba ou viré brusquement course à sa
criée dans l'autre côté non ma vie est
beau parce que justement après un
macaque virois komotini raison parce que
sa réalité c'est ma d'un pays à ses
projets à pia et comme
new river à des situations où il a
reproché - et du moins bon mais c'est le
maire oignons projet territoire on ebay
pouffer nour a proposé aux as et comment
estimez que c'est un mec t'es bon bah
pays
la dgos m'a dit pourquoi pas nitoo ouais
bon maintenant comme moitié du causse en
avant et jusqu'à présent mon pack jamais
un coin qui me font projet baadiko ce et
simon pegg témoins mais parfois jusqu'à
présent moi aller devant tribunal niveau
pour détournement de fonds ni pouchès de
malentendus et cetera ni fort ni culture
rien du tout tout projet mais ici avec
la main de dieu ouais ducos troisième
ville au point de vue du plan économique
le plus gros chiffre d'affires la
martinique c'est parce que l'ail et
ouais bof moi pas fait dans moins de
deux mois estimé que les projets à
montaigne un très bon non pour la
martinique pour ducos mais à ce moment
là mon cas steam et que ce repas bien
nouveau ouais regardez ici à ma vie
alors que nous habitons sort a dit à
mathieu lui même et qu'elle nous a coûté
os que quelque part ou pas en situation
d'échec personnel non plus parce que
finalement le arrivé en 2000 et puis en
l'équipe ou par match comme une lan et
puis ensuite pour paris match et c'est
par match et matinik et que ou cadres
équipe ou même panier sont capables de
prendre la relève du ski au crédit
compagnie confiance et qui pourra dire
que pagny relève quelques pompes arrivée
transmettre le flambeau
mon père me disait nous enlève un nom
pas j'aime indiqué en bonne compagnie
moon un espace à - dire va pas fermer 10
heures au contraire ni à l'organisation
n'a pas organisé couillaud mais moins
mapaq a dit jean jacques arrighi albert
non ces peuples aient choisi c'est du
moment et les moyens 2001 m'étais dit
c'était demande à nos clés nous saq
passé et puis premier adjoint au maire
de même fait rage non pas qu'elle votre
amitié et et harmonie
alors maintenant mon casting make money
projet va du course pour 2035 et come
back a fait long confiance mécanique un
projet hip hop que d'avenir est il qu'à
permettre ces jeunes à huit vous verrez
au ballon l'espoir et comment les reculs
et mac a estimé que faut combien du good
way est un magasin pensaient qu'elle
serait passé le témoin le relais pour
dire leur ordi - oui ou non et puis leur
épaisseur de bagages est-ce que c'est
pas sûr de techniques de ciudad y en
aura six mètres du but la maladie n'a
pas calé pour mondeville idiot miceli
mérite ou mérite n'est pas ce que pense
et personne d'autre qui ou non non non
non non non tu ne m'as pas je me dis
personne de kim non encore aux contes et
c'est justement si materis depuis mai
comme aux courses à ma sécurité puisque
mon cap mounier l'impression qu'elle
passait pas ni d'autres crimes non
européens c'est justement il faut que
bien plus de conscience bas et qui lui
ont dit voilà effectivement shannon
devine y déjà landry fait monter
peut-être fait autant et c'est peut-être
parce que juste volé montella n'a dira
oui au oui si celle du préfet est
jalonnée fait aussi fait aussi alors
maryse nancy société adjoint aurélie
n'est latéral elle lisse ou dernier
l'action municipale et pini louis
morissette quitté adversaires ou qui
tournait à lyon pour décembre 2015 nous
est dit que ou presque tout maintenant
les bouches un parmi toutes ces
mondanités prétend djia à la ville de
ducos qui sont radio msc au goût du
travail est-ce qu'il ya là une manière
ça c'est ayo ouais mais moi des fois no
dijo dia que si on allait souvent timina
lequel nous avons été assez pour
défendre des projets est imminente et a
estimé qu itté bobadilla mais par le
juge alain denis faye fournitures c'est
important
c'est important parce que les décisions
se prennent au niveau politique pourquoi
pas seulement pathé jamais ni le jazz ou
la politique d'abord mais comme un
certain moment là d'humains fin d aller
vendredi à l'aide d'imagés du ballon et
en plus administratif tu as des
attributions de gestion dont le bas
géants comme concept
non et de ce fait nous dit pas si mal et
fléchit que les décisions se prennent au
niveau politique et comme la politique
et pour qui ça bureau politique équipe
là qui actuellement en place la mairie
du cos pour qu'ils aillent au parc à ce
sujet qu'il y aura des réunions c'est à
dire une politique groupe bureau
politique du clan pour qu'ils vaquent à
siéger en représailles au pack à sion
j'ai piloté cloud center
oui mais je n'ai jamais chaque montagne
à vision et mon clavier du mouvement
politiciens ils m'ont toujours dit que
ma part les faits la politique est un
policier de la corruption
d'accord mais la vraie politique se sont
depuis déjà fait déjà de la city et
c'est ça ma compagnie et les décisions
se prennent au niveau politique et ça me
concernait justement colonie des
politiciens qui pourquoi mais pourquoi
roussel mais pas pour l'intérêt général
hamon pas les augmenter le nom charles
andré mancey à dos tout baguette à la
haye ce que c'est pas peut-être les
difficultés financières également de la
ville de ducos qui a fait que ou envie
de cordoba et avons envie profiter de
quand il ment de tyrie très tout
tranquillement puisque nous qui
handicaperait demain nous qui étaient
laissés konoha budget commune en 32
millions à peu près de deux budgets et
puis un déficit presque 2 millions est
ce que ça c'est par un bagad normal tête
parce qu'en fait ce n'est pas du tout
pas du tout aux seuls muntari budget de
nos les poubelles assez petit monde a
écrit mais moins en âme et conscience -
moussa auquel faut créer les richesses
ne savent pas tous les jours faut pas
nous appeler réis l'état s'est désengagé
de la cda neige d'accord et c'est sam en
comprendre des plus grands bonnets nous
sommes il faut qu'il aille jusque là que
j'ai c'est la gestion économe du sol et
la distribuer de l'espace où il fait ça
oui ouais et l'ajustement kadima papeete
- puis sur des marchés cette église
c'était qu'un manque à fonctionner mon
pas besoin ni communauté ni que
l'activité autre est plus gros et plus
tard et puis nous
ducos nous peut fonctionner c'est au
jour d'aujourd'hui entrée 10 cm la
septième manche face à quel point ces
tailles au mur après son habilité mois à
ce jour dix jours et il demande beaucoup
me convainquent avancées comme la 7e
combiné valable à la communauté par
hélico seulement et ils peuvent avoir
une subvention tenir une conversation
nous indiquons yapi le cogneur non non
non non la manière de dire les choses
montre bien la manière dont on y voit sa
compagne en personne au contraire aux
coutumes un malaise
le seul problème c'était ben ali publiés
par couple ouais alors pour finir souza
fait cher à faible budget a fait
l'argent eh bien nous l'avons constaté
ça nous met en place une stratégie
fiscale en stratégie financière et
stratégie sociale et claudia le cully
fukuda dit ouais qui maniait nous peut
connecter tournon mécary qui mène au
plat la fiscalité qui maintient nos
peurs et la direction générale des
finances publiques pour dire aux aguets
faut que accompagner nos l'est par
exemple un mauvais ce moment le terrain
puis regardez sa qualité rien et puis
c'est fish l'a pas traiter la même
qu'avant - and the city achètera banc
narbonnais ont régularisé les documents
balles de suite
pour nous ça fait rire cette intrigue le
dimanche sa stratégie financière l'avait
vu comment cacher c'est tout témoigne un
mois riesch est différemment la
stratégie sociale c'est justement pour
le personnel gagner au kenya pour
évoluer pour nous gagner aussitôt
manière pour nous éviter diminué
association passe à 100 c'est sans
jardin de 2,2 de carnaval c'est oui ils
financent de l'agent par l'agent maudire
nous marions nous nous coiffer l'argent
alors justement puisque aucun bailleur
social puisqu'on avait de social
jusqu'au pourquoi pas et de personnel
l'amérique du cos alors que mon mal
tente peut-être que malte sont peut-être
que yo ma le dit - mais d'après sam en
comprendre toutes ces cas de l'acquis la
mairie du cossu en situation de
souffrance extrême parce qu'un monsieur
l'imec à accepter le diktat ses dires
syndicats locaux triés la cgtm soem mais
faux grillon de la même famille sont pas
les syndicats
bravo nos bleus
sa maman les filles aussi c'est que
justement un des matches là mon café a
aussi à et maccarone résultat la chambre
régionale des comptes pour agir vous
tapez un fonctionnement nous payer ou
autour pour l'argent qu'à payer moon
vous fait au pouvoir ça il faut - man ou
à jouer le faux cul ya que moi je
m'étais qu un travail heureusement quand
même que macca mapaq a fait dictateur
monnier un partenaire social 80 et puis
oui heureusement non non non c'est pas
laissez pas influencer par il peut
influencer - ic accompagné - parce
qu'heureusement il a passé 6 bat et là
un jour dijoux démocratique avoir marqué
les 30 et social mobile et la tv
merci chalandre heymans et de tv ni bon
matière dans son caddie de rappeler que
ces housses et mais la commune la mairie
du cosmétique bonne journée à vous même
[Musique]